I want to talk about the greatest moment
of your career I hope you don't mind it
is of course when you were asked in an
interview what would you be if you
weren't a footballer and you replied a
virgin that's the day the legend of
Crouch you began followed you round I
always tell ya house a lot yeah the best
answer to any question in any ever well
it was just a long baby to be honest
that came to mind and I said it and yeah
like like 10 years or however many years
later it's people still talk about it
but you've come on from there you're now
married to the wonderful Abbey hmm
what's this waiter what's his game here
was Alex Turner from the Arctic Monkeys
actually give me the side eye emoji how
did he Nick that this is the thing that
you say the people come up to you and
they just have no like was there an
incident with Prince Harry yes there was
yeah no I was playing a charity game and
then and he came to the drill into the
dressing room and was meeting everyone
and he was really friendly to everyone
and then when I when I met him he said
kraji I said yes and he said how did you
bag a bee I love supreme free Megan so
you know now I could about go back in
and there goes crouch cheese night
[Music]